los 14 expertos internacionales de la
organización mundial de la salud han
salido esta tarde del hotel de wuhan
tras haber cumplido las dos semanas
preceptivas que pone china a todos los
llegados de fuera y han sido trasladados
a este otro hotel donde hoy mantendrán
la primera reunión presencial con sus
colegas chinos para intercambiar
información han llegado hasta aquí para
averiguar cómo cuándo y dónde se originó
la pandemia no han trascendido por ahora
muchos detalles del calendario se sabe
que visitarán el mercado de juana no y
cerrado y tapado por una enorme valla
azul y en el que surgieron los primeros
casos de lo que entonces se llamó una
neumonía misteriosa también visitarán el
hospital que los atendió allá se
analizarán las muestras de sangre que
rutinariamente almacenaba antes de que
estallara la pandemia con las
conclusiones que se saquen después de
visitar estos dos lugares se diseñará el
resto de la misión que podría llevarlos
a las provincias vecinas o incluso a
países del sudeste asiático ya han
alertado los expertos que va a ser muy
complicado que den con el paciente cero
pero sí que es más factible
si la pandemia realmente se originó aquí
en luján o solo fue detectada después de
que circulara durante meses entre
nosotros